Call of Duty infinite warfare has a ton
of weapons to unlock but you can also
tweak them just the way you want I'm
Tony and this is your custom gamespot
news update just like with past call of
duty games you'll unlock new weapons as
you level up but you also unlock
prototype versions of the same guns they
come in different tears from commenter
air to legendary to epic and each one
has its own set of perks you can also
craft prototypes using salvaged which
can be earned quote in a variety of ways
while playing the game all of this means
that you'll be able to construct the
best possible weapon for your play style
infinite warfare comes to ps4 xbox one
and pc on november 4th special editions
of the game include modern warfare
remastered and if you pre-ordered one of
those on ps4 you can actually play
modern warfare full campaign right now
stay tuned to gamespot for more coverage
on launch day and for all the biggest
call of duty news you're already in the
right place